>> Let's visualize what we did here. We have a bunch of data values and we found
the mean, let's say it's here. Then we found the distance between each value and
the mean and then squared them. This is essentially the area of every square
whose side length is the distance between each value and the mean. So we all of
these squares and the sum of squares is basically the sum of the area of each
square where each distance is Xi minus X-bar and each area is Xi minus X-bar
squared. So then we find the average square. So the average square might be
something like this size, let's say. In this case, the dimensions are in
dollars. So the area of this square would have units of dollars squared. So, how
do we convert this back to just dollars? Take the square root, divide by 2, or
subtract one dollar sign?